J'ai vu quelque chose ce jour-là quelque chose que
je n'oublierai pas
il mesure 12 pieds de haut
avec des griffes acérées
comme des rasoirs et une peau jonchée d'armes de
guerriers tombés au combat
ce visage marqué par un œil mort
un rêve une épée la jambe
de papa était propre oh c'est ma
partie préférée
conformément à nos lois, le
premier-né de chacun des grands dirigeants
doit prouver sa valeur
une dame aime les activités élégantes
je présente
mon fils unique
il a éliminé toute une armada à lui
seul
avec un bras il volait le navire
je veux ma liberté
mais je suis  tu es prêt à payer le prix que coûtera
ta liberté, fais
attention à ce que tu souhaites pour ma mère, je
dirais quel est le pire qui puisse
arriver,
ne te bats plus, bien sûr, un petit décorum
régalera tes yeux
si tu avais la chance de changer de
pied, n'est-ce pas ?